I'm listening to a tape of this uh kid
who does an impression of me and it's
[ __ ] me up because now I'm here when
I'm talking I hear I sound like the guy
this kid's name is Matt friend we had
Dana Carvey one of my favorites on as a
guest and we were talking about how
nobody does a good impression of me even
on SNL nobody's been able to do it now
there's this one guy who's 23 years old
he does an impression of me on Tick Tock
or whatever you want to call it I think
it's okay I mean I I don't think it
sounds much like me you know then all of
a sudden I was talking and I said I kind
of sound a lot I can hear it a little
bit you know all right and now it's
[ __ ] me up
hey is this uh Howard on the phone you
know I gotta tell you now first of all
that was unfair to me because you played
a clip from two years ago and the voice
has evolved as you know it's great to
meet you I guess I do sound a little bit
like that
you really do but you're fantastic I
hear what you're doing and I think
you're on to something I honestly do
well are you making a living doing the
Howard Stern impression or is it just a
hobby I'm doing it among others yeah I'm
making a living as a as a full-time
comedian in New York nice I started
doing impressions as a little kid you've
always been one of my favorites I've
observed about you what you do it you're
one beat away from Alan Alder and I talk
about this all the time because you're a
bit lower you're down here and then Alan
you bring it up he's a little bit higher
[ __ ] but uh that's the amazing thing
about Impressionists they have that they
they hear that difference and they
change that register and all of a sudden
you go yeah that is Alan Matt's got
something going on I have to say I've
never really been impressed with anyone
who did an impression of me but Matt you
know I I hear it now you know man I hear
it
foreign